Українці Наталя та Петро Мельники вже четвертий рік живуть і працюють у Польщі.
Подружжя медиків наважилося на переїзд, коли обом було за 40, бо жити на лікарські зарплати в Україні далі було не сила.
Я працювала на півтори ставки і отримувала біля 6 тисяч гривень на руки. Це, фактично, цілий день працювати - і таку зарплату мати.
А чоловік теж мав декілька спеціалізацій: і хірург, і проктолог, і ендоскопіст, і також лікарем приймального відділення працював. Теж на півтори ставки.
І ще, крім того, мав чергування нічні дуже часто. Ну, і на руки теж виходило біля 6 тисяч гривень. І це просто смішні зарплати.
На такі зарплати неможливо було б прожити. Фактично, ми жили за рахунок допомоги родичів.
До Польщі Мельники переїхали зі Львівської області у 2017-му.
Однак без належного знання мови і легалізації українських дипломів знайти роботу за фахом їм не вдалося.
Тому лікарі спершу влаштувалися на завод з виробництва автомобільних фар.
Після роботи чоловік готувався до складних іспитів, аби підтвердити свій український диплом і отримати ліцензію лікаря.
Екзамени Петро успішно склав. Потім ще рік відпрацював у місцевій лікарні на волонтерських засадах.
І лише навесні 2020 Мельникам вдалося отримати роботу в лікарні невеликого міста Хшанув.
Ми коли працювали на заводі, то ходили попри ту лікарню на завод. І ми собі дали слово, що будемо там працювати обоє.
Звичайно, я як рентгенолог-лаборант отримую як середній працівник, я не лікар, то я можу заробити в гривнях приблизно до 40 тисяч.
А чоловік працює на трьох відділеннях, то він може заробити 100 тисяч гривень, у середньому 120-150. То залежить, скільки він має чергувань.
В Україні такі зарплати не отримують навіть працівники приватних клінік, не кажучи вже про державні медзаклади.
За даними НСЗУ, у середньому лікарі спеціалізованої допомоги торік заробляли 9 тисяч гривень,
а середній і молодший персонал - 7,5 і 6 тисяч гривень відповідно, з яких ще мали сплатити податки.
На сайтах, що пропонують роботу, десятки оголошень з вакансіями для медиків. Серед них легко розпізнати українських й закордонних роботодавців.
Заробітні плати відрізняються в рази. Експерти наголошують: нині європейські клініки як ніколи активно "полюють" на кваліфіковані медичні кадри в Україні.
На сьогодні до нашої асоціації звертаються представники Польщі, Італії, Німеччини, котрим потрібні саме працівники у медичній сфері.
Потрібні всі напрямки: від медичних сестер до лікарів-анестезіологів, від хірургів до звичайних дантистів.
Якщо казати про нестачу кадрів, то за деякими даними в Німеччині не вистачає приблизно 100 тисяч медсестер станом на 2019 рік.
У системі охорони здоров’я Польщі не вистачає майже 68 тисяч медперсоналу.
Тому, звісно, зацікавленість дуже висока, а пандемія підштовхнула взагалі весь світ до розуміння того,
що без наявності достатньо великої кількості медичного персоналу неможливо допомогти своїм громадянам.
Скільки медиків вже емігрували з України - достеменно не відомо. Офіційної статистики ніхто не веде.
Лік пішов на сотні, кажуть компанії, які займаються працевлаштуванням лікарів до інших країн.
Так, наприкінці минулого року Польща полегшила працевлаштування для іноземних лікарів.
Тепер, щоб отримати роботу в польському медзакладі, достатньо мати диплом лікаря, досвід роботи від 3 років, а також знати польську мову.
Щоправда, такі лікарі отримуватимуть вдвічі менше, ніж ті українські колеги, що здали усі необхідні іспити й офіційно підтвердили свій диплом.
Після вступу цього закону починають дзвонити лікарі і запитують: а садочок, а школа. Тому що всі планують з дітьми переїжджати.
Є багато нюансів, які треба вирішити перед переїздом. Тому це не буде так, що мільйон лікарів сядуть і поїдуть працювати в Польщу.
Але, звісно, коли зробили біометричні паспорти, звісно, збільшилася кількість. І збільшується кількість також за рахунок студентів.
Серед молодих фахівців, які по закінченні університету одразу їдуть працювати за кордон, й Анастасія Бабінець.
Дівчина, пропрацювавши в Україні лише 4 місяці, після практики в Німеччині вирішила емігрувати
і влаштувалася неврологом у реабілітаційну клініку міста Бад-Тенштедт.
І ти очікуєш, що, закінчивши університет, зможеш нормально заробляти, зможеш свою сім'ю підтримати. Це все неможливо.
І приходить тоді розчарування, і люди вирішують їхати.  Якраз моя зарплата була від 4500 до 6000 гривень, вона коливалася.
То так само лікарська зарплата орієнтовно - тільки в євро.
У Міністерстві охорони здоров’я вже визнали, що відтік медичного персоналу - значна проблема.
Я вважаю, що це питання саме національної безпеки.
Навіть тисяча сучасних лікарень будуть нам просто непотрібні. Лікарні, які будуть обладнані за найновішими технологіями, де буде підведено кисень,
будуть стояти ліжка, монітори пацієнтів, але біля цього ліжка не буде наших медичних працівників.
Просто вдумайтеся в це. Це не якийсь апокаліптичний фільм, це та наша реальність, яка може статися в нашій країні.
У МОЗ розраховували підвищити зарплати лікарів у 2021 році до 23 тисяч гривень, 17 тисяч гривень мав би отримувати середній медичний персонал
і 12 тисяч - молодший. Однак у бюджеті грошей на таке підвищення не заклали.
На думку Василя Воскобойника, відтік лікарів незворотний і Україні вже нині слід подумати про залучення спеціалістів з інших країн.
Питання, яке з’являється одразу: а хто буде лікувати українців? Україні на сьогодні потрібно вибудовувати вже свою міграційну політику.
І намагатися шукати країни і громадян тих країн, які будуть приїздити до України і залишатися тут.
На мій погляд, до нас можуть поїхати мешканці Білорусі, Росії, країн середньої Азії.
Тим часом медики-емігранти Анастасія Бабінець і подружжя Мельників поки не планують повертатися в Україну.
Ми не шкодуємо жодної хвилини, і якби нам зараз сказали повертатися в Україну, звичайно, ми би не повернулися.
Тому що, по-перше, дуже добре ставлення тут до лікарів.
І поки Україна не дасть лікарю зарплату мінімум 50 тисяч гривень зарплати лікарю, то лікарі не будуть працювати на таку зарплату.
Ми, власне, збираємо документи і подаємося на громадянство.
Експерти наголошують, масовий відтік медичного персоналу з України може початися по закінченні пандемії.
Адже тоді лікарі, що працюють з хворими на "ковід", перестануть отримувати 300% надбавки до зарплатні.
За даними НСЗУ, зараз в Україні зареєстровано понад 96 тисяч лікарів спеціалізованої медичної допомоги.
І в 2020 році вже бракувало 5 тисяч працівників медико-профілактичного профілю, здебільшого вірусологів, інфекціоністів та педіатрів.